so I put it out there then I wanted to
roast a big city police department and
the only one to step up and say yes
was the home of America's very first
police force Boston a city that I've
loved since going to college there but
on the morning I arrived an officer was
shot and tensions were running high you
know this individual just shot one of
our officers and the officers were able
to tackle him and not use deadly force I
don't know the details what happened in
Dorchester but cop gets shot
they could have they could have killed
the guy his partner could have killed
the guy you know the officers Rhian him
down and tackled him when they could
have used deadly force but I I like to
say uh you know we're a compassionate
department and we care about human life
and I think the public realizes that
I've often just have a bad reputation
well when I came on the job we had 160
homicides
we had 38 this year Chicago had 500
Baltimore had 344 so des stricter gun
laws in the community work we're doing
is really making a difference why would
you let me come in and roast the Boston
Police Department well I would because
you know I want to break the stereotype
out there that you know we're the bad
guys I wanted people to see that what's
playing out across the nation isn't what
the Boston Police are we don't mind you
making fun of us because I want the
public to know we're real people you got
a nose for crime I uh
well here's for it too now that the
brass was on board I was revved up and
ready to address the rank and file
during an afternoon roll call and give
him a few laughs before they hit the
streets
[Music]
how are you everybody I'll make this
quick as I know most of you a
double-parked thank you for letting me
come here this is really cool I've never
performed in front of an entire roomful
of YouTube celebrities before this would
be so much better if you guys just came
in the middle room all right fine you
guys also have a rich criminal history
in this town you had the Boston Tea
Party here Whitey Bulger was from here
Tom Brady's from here oh come on that
one buddy let the air out of the room
huh let's be real if whitey Bulger's
name had been Blackie Bulger they would
have caught him a lot quicker Jesus
Christ there's obviously a problem
between the cops and the community
across the country right now and that's
what I'm here because that really
bothers me and it really bothers me when
some people say that all cops are racist
of course that's not true most of you it
just sticks to everybody all right well
thanks for coming all right
thanks you guys holy that sucked
hasn't there been enough bombing in
Boston well it turns out that right
before I got to town the policemen's
Union found a picture of me at black
lives matter rally and profiled me as a
cop hater they even posted a bulletin in
all the precincts and sent an email to
every cop in town telling them to stay
away from me with no cameras allowed I
spent hours negotiating my comedy
special out of a hostage situation
[Applause]
[Music]